all the rumors are true yeah yes the
rumors are true that lizzo won a vma on
sunday night
but where was she oh my god on monday
the singer addressed her absence at the
2021 video music awards winning the moon
person for the best artist by creator
collab category for this tik tok mustard
watermelon
i don't understand lizzo fittingly took
to tick-tock to thank her fans with the
caption we won at mtv vma for a tick
tock besties we did it where my moon man
at also revealing the real reason she
couldn't make it to the event god damn
all the rumors are true yeah what you
heard that's true yeah [ __ ] him and you
yeah if you believe i yep that's lizzo
admitting quote i really want a vma
while i was getting my backbone out last
night i'll be there next year promise
i got enough to give there's enough
lizzo for everybody rumors is lizzo's
first single in two years following the
breakout success of her album cause i
love you
and since the release she's seemingly
been spending a lot of time at home even
taking time to watch the spider-man film
with tom holland and zendaya
so i have a confession to make i have
not seen a spider-man movie since toby
maguire i've been on tour
rocking out
running all over the place not having
tvs sleeping on my friends couches
and floors
so
i've been seeing a lot of tick tocks
about just like the new one
um with um
with tom holland and he just looks like
so funny and so interesting as peter
parker so i'm gonna watch it tonight and
zendaya hello and last week the singer
even surprised her mom with a brand new
wardrobe writing in the caption ever
since daddy passed you've been telling
me it's hard to dress nice for yourself
i can't bring your best friend back but
i can give you this happy b day mom
you like these clothes
these are your clothes
look at the clothes
[Music]
no ma'am not on my watch
lizzo's mom even gave us an impromptu
fashion show of some of her new items
this is cute
[Music]
what comes next from lizzo is a question
mark rumors is seemingly the lead single
off her next record but we have no intel
on when that comes out back in 2019
lizzo told et taking time on her art and
prioritizing self-care are important to
her i want to feel good like i
um when i was younger i had a friend who
was always helping me out with self-care
and he would be like you know you gotta
take some time to meditate and you gotta
eat bagels with cream cheese and you
gotta chill and i was like you're so
good at this you're so good at being
happy and he was like well i'm only good
at being happy because i was so sad i
need it the most and you know it's the
same with me like i need this music to
be my therapy because i have been solo
and i refuse to you know live life like
that anymore
[Music]